yo con el tiempo me di cuenta me detail
que el daño le ocasione a mi familia
no a mis hijos
a mi madre
porque en si ellos fueron los que se
sintieron más mal que yo y eso me duele
no por qué
ellos fueron los afectados
l mi hijo
[Música]
se avenga a las personas que tengan la
situación económica precaria ven a las
personas que estén pasando por cosas así
no entonces necesidades económicas
entonces ellos buscan ellos ven quienes
en este caso el caso fue mío
i
[Música]
y aquí son bastantes mulas muchas porque
nosotros venimos por encargo no para por
un pago en el caso mío a mí me van a
pagar dos mil dólares para operarme mis
ojos pero nunca lo vi nunca me entienden
nada más y los dueños ellos están libres
por eso que no los detienen y yo no sé
por qué
[Música]
hay dos dificultades enormes una es el
idioma que la mayoría la gran mayoría no
maneja nada de inglés cuando llega mucho
menos chino y la segunda es cuando caen
en cuenta que están aquí
a miles de kilómetros de distancia de
sus familias que están solas muchas de
ellas sobre todo las que tienen niños
pequeños pues caen en la cuenta que tal
vez por años
no van a volver a ver a sus hijos
[Música]
ah
en
[Música]
el
fútbol inglés
y
si se portan
[Música]